I was fascinated by the fact cuz I
didn't do any homework yeah that this
guy that I don't really know on a show
that I never watched Tom sandal did you
hear of Scandal Scandal is so cool that
I I love that no I did not hear of it at
all oh CU I didn't know anything about
it but in just general news he told her
he cheated on her because when they had
sex she'd wear a T-shirt and then she
sold t-shirts well you would get in
trouble if you had them on you should
have them on you should have him on he
has a podcast now oh I want to have it
hly you should have him on and don't do
any homework and I'm telling you this
Bravo audience they will [__] burn
you alive oh I want it I need it I'm
going to request it I didn't I knew as
much as you knew but I said why don't
you come on and school me why don't you
tell me what you what happened and he
did it he came on because uh one of my
um people that work here yeah in the
television development yeah her husband
is his manager and his drummer so I said
I won't his drummer yeah he makes music
yeah he has a band Tom and the most
extras wow now he's starting to sound
like someone I would date you know maybe
I get cheated on next anyway you want do
you wanna do you want to be with Tom
sandal we could work it out I don't
think I even know what he looks like
honestly um we could put but so he came
on and he schooled you well he just told
me I said why is this on CNN why is this
above like I only know about you and
Ashley because I've clicked on you and I
know resarch this was like worldwide
there he is this there he is that's Tom
S is that your type I love a good
mustache I shaved it off here on the
podcast I shaved it off you shaved off
his mustache yeah cuz I thought it would
make him more uh approachable I thought
he was getting a lot of hate wow that's
kind of crazy what I think I like men
who aren't approachable cuz without the
mustache it's like no do you what so
what do you think cck on Special Forces
one where he Special Forces oh and he's
friends with JoJo now he is yeah and
they were on Special
Forces yeah that show is crazy I would
die probably love to have you on there
he is now without the
mustache picture what the f i gu guess I
guess he's like cute but no I'm kidding
I don't I don't want all that no but
there he is there he is he cheated with
his partner of I like that this is him
like if you just bump into him literally
if you un approachable he's
unapproachable I do normally love he
puts uh no because he that's why he's
he's a lot older than he seems but he
puts period blood on his face oh wow so
that's where the skin has at I was going
to yeah okay anyway the point is that
can the people at home see this this
picture yeah they could see it okay so
um what I was going to say is I didn't
understand why him cheating I I I'm not
for cheating I hate cheating I would
kill somebody who cheated on
I would never cheat and I would if
somebody cheated on my daughter I would
you know it they would they would die
they would die so the point is they
thought I was condoning this but I was
saying why is this such big news why is
it bigger news than you and Ashley
well well what I mean Vander pump rules
is huge super mainstream I feel like the
like Xanax wine moms love Vander pump
rules you know the Xanax wine M you know
the
Bravo con you know the one have you been
to Bravo con no what is Bravo con what
you think it is it's all the people who
watch those Bravo shows and fan girl
over all the shows right the housewives
it's huge right huge and Coen Andy Cohen
runs it don't you go to a
[Music]
con